we found out last night
that the ndp and the liberals were
meeting secretly and they've cooked up a
backroom deal
that would see justin trudeau get the
majority power that he tried desperately
to get last fall in the last election
but he failed to get
this deal means the canadians have woken
up to an
in essence an ndp liberal majority
government
and i think we have to let that sink in
this is an ndp
liberal government and they have the
majority
82 percent of voters did not vote for a
liberal ndp government inc including
millions of liberal voters
these canadians woke up this morning to
the fact that they have been hoodwinked
and they've been deceived by their prime
minister
now let me be clear this is nothing more
than a justin trudeau
power grab he is desperately clinging to
power his number one goal as we have
seen over the course of the last six
years
is always to do what's best for him
not to do what's best for canadians
now make no mistake the ndp are in
charge
what does this mean well it means the
decimation of canadian oil and gas and
lng
which we now more we know this more than
ever that means that that is really a
way to prop up putin and russia when the
ndp liberal government
phase out which means destroy canadian
oil gas and lng they are helping russia
and that was one of the top priorities
they had and that justin trudeau has
agreed to
it means mining agriculture fisheries
are are all next under the extreme
policies of the ndp which are now
liberal policies it also means 214
billion dollars just that we know of in
new spending for canadians and that's
who's going to be spending that's who's
going to be bearing the brunt of the new
ndp liberal government
all of which canadians for canadians
means more debt more inflation more jobs
lost
more uncertainty and frankly more
polarization
this is not a good day for canadians
but i cannot imagine that all liberals
are comfortable with this there are many
liberals that are uh you know fiscally
responsible there are many obviously
many millions of liberal voters i
believe who are fiscally responsible
that support canadian
natural resources that support canadian
have an investment grow in canada there
are a lot of liberals that are coming to
me and saying they're very worried about
the economic direction under a justin
trudeau government i cannot imagine this
morning how they are feeling knowing
that we now have a jug meat singh
led because he's basically going to be
the deputy prime minister this is a
formal written agreement we now have a
ndp liberal government in charge so i am
fairly certain there are literally
millions of liberal voters including
some liberal and members of parliament
who have got to be very concerned this
morning i think the announcement we
heard this morning is very clear the
justin trudeau has basically said uh
what i told canadians i would do three
four five months ago in the election
i've changed my mind because i actually
want to feel and know that i have a
majority of majority power and so i will
do basically anything the ndp asked me
to do in order to keep that power i
think that that is proof enough and and
i mean we already have seen uh trudeau
and his policy move further and further
to the left this is a man who wasn't
joking when he said he doesn't think
about monetary policy this is a man that
has was not joking when he says he
admires china's basic dictatorship he
admires
very left very extreme
ways of governing and governance
and so when he has now formed a full
formal agreement with the ndp government
with the ndp party who's now the
basically the government
he has deceived canadians and i i think
there there's got to be a lot of concern
not just with canadians but with liberal
voters themselves
what what lengths will this man go to to
cling to power
but i believe it goes to the heart of
our democracy
they had the liberals in the ndp
had and have an obligation to be honest
and transparent and tell canadians this
is what they've been cooking up and they
didn't do that they cannot be trusted
these parties cannot be trusted neither
of these men can be trusted to do what's
best for the country so a lot of
implications we have a lot of work to do
and we're going to
we're going to get to work doing that
thank you very much